what the is going on I like to party
Jesus honey wax this is unwaxed get in
lizard we're going shopping with Sophia
and cine Salone did we just become best
friends
[Music]
y hello everybody and welcome back to
another episode of the unwax podcast
with your favorite sisters sine and
Sophia happy New Year guys 2024 baby
round of applause for all of you we
lasted another year this was a year I
feel like I've read a lot of people
saying that this was their best year I
don't know what kind of year you had I
was just going to say that everyone was
saying you know want to know why why the
people that are posting that 2023 was
their greatest year were engaged and
with child within that year or married
with child in that year so yeah that's a
big year for you what did we do a lot of
crying a lot of a lot of traveling
crying a lot of self-doubt breakups
makeouts a lot of rejection a lot of
really maybe just maybe onesided maybe
just me no but I I was say to to I went
to the doctors this morning and I was
writing out 2023 every single time I had
to fill out a paperwork I'm still it's I
mean it's only been a couple days but it
feels like this year has flown by so
fast you know when you hear parents say
as you get older the years feel faster I
never really understood that until now
oh seriously yeah it was so weird when
Christmas came around because I swear I
just finished shopping for your guys'
gifts like two weeks before right and
then here we are again no it's it's
baffling I feel like I saw and when you
go back to saying oh like think about
the good times don't waste your use it's
so quick it flies by I saw a photo of
downtown LA the other day and it made me
think of college because I lived in
Downtown LA and I it was the first time
I've ever thought this in my head and I
go God I would just w i what I would do
just go back in that moment and just
experience that again how I was so young
I was 22 living in Downtown LA in
college and I was dating and having fun
I'm like what I know I'd love to correct
you though you guys it wasn't a photo of
downtown LA we were playing Grand Theft
Auto and we were driving through
downtown LA okay we were playing Grand
Theft Auto you didn't just look at a
photo so that's that's how our year has
started so far a lot of video games
we're still in Florida if you can't
recognize the set we are back in Palm
Beach um going a little stir crazy and I
think that's something that isn't talked
about enough I love my family I love my
sisters I love my parents but it's hit
that time where I feel like I am
grounded I'm under house arrest I feel
13 having to ask permission to go out
everyone feels this way everyone feels
like when you live with your parents you
feel like you are back at the age that
you were which 15 14 whatever it is I
mean mom does ask us go get the
groceries clean your room I mean look I
love it just because I love the polar
difference between having not hear a
garbage truck man at 2 a.m. outside my
window screaming waking me up to now the
ocean it's a bit nicer I would say but I
would love to get into all of the big
life changes that we already have lined
up for ourselves in the next year but I
think we should tap into our New Year's
PL yes I was just going to say which by
the way is the most overrated holiday
can we all agree on this New Year's is
so overrated and it's so not the hype
I've never had like the most ultimate
New Year's ever I have more fun on St
Patrick's Day I have more fun on Quanza
I have more fun on Columbus
Day New Year's Day is the most
disappointing day of the year because if
you're single it's pretty goddamn
miserable would you not agree no it's
totally miserable time in here no I'm
sorry I'm like okay you want to know
something funny all right Sophia said
this morning she had a doctor's
appointment she was getting an MRI on
her brain what is going on with you
Sophia no I just I honestly first off
I'm so tired and out of it because I've
been up since like 5 but I have a I had
um I have a bunch of migraines lately so
my doctor said he just wanted to get me
checked but I actually saw a of my brain
what a beautiful looking thing it's huge
is it a peanut it's not I said it's huge
it's it looks squishy too it looks like
it looks like one of those um trying to
think of those molding balls when you're
younger and you a stress ball almost but
like a little play play almost like
Play-Doh it was really cool I got to see
the lines everything oh back to what we
were saying about New Year because
obviously that's a great start to New
Year's I got an ey on my brain um okay
go ahead no no I said my part do you
remember anything I just said I'm so
sorry I promise I'm in it I'm invested
I'm invested I'm invested I was just
reading something so this next year I'm
actually doing the podcast
solo and I'm really excited to do this
endeavor on my own because clearly you
can't trust noo to do the work no
obviously not okay so what we did for
New Year's was we came into Florida
thinking you know sis I thought we
didn't want to over plan we didn't want
to over spend money but then we were
like we really want to have fun so we
said let's go to Miami since Scarlet's
there that could be really fun she knows
the places and then we just uh realized
it was a little bit too much and we got
tired and we decided to not do that and
we decided to stay in Palm Beach instead
with no plans you know at first our plan
was we were going to sit under the table
and eat 12 grapes in a red thong and
then we said that's a little pathetic
okay well we told you guys we were going
to do it and so bought me a red thong
for Christmas and grapes and grapes not
for you I might buy me grapes for
Christmas but we bought grapes for
obviously I didn't buy you grapes for
Christmas what is wrong with you right
now why you see what's wrong with you
bro all right here's what happened my
dad actually came in with the party
invite he goes girls I got you the most
exclusive party in Palm Beach we're
going it's going to be amazing so I said
fantastic I dressed for New Year's right
tight dress tits out we're ready to
party we walk in it is a black tie
event 1920s flapper theme
1920s black tie event ctin and I are
wearing body con mini dresses with
Stilettos and big eye makeup we had
stairs but not the good kind we oh it
was not the good kind everyone was in
and it's Palm Beach everyone was also
over the age of 60 everyone wore the top
Elite designer ball counts it's Palm
Beach no one's showing up to these
places looking like half ass they are
coming in full-fledged with hair and
makeup and they looked good they good we
looked like the 1920s [__] on the
street that you would pick up no they
don't call them [__] what are they
called
harlots ladies of the night Mistresses I
like that we were ladies of the night we
definitely didn't look we didn't look
the part and I was so embarrassed well
the funny thing is is my mom didn't know
this either so and you know my mom our
mom is the person that she if she knew
this she would have told us and reminded
us to BU address four months ahead of
time that's her emmo my dad on the other
hand will not tell us anything he'll
just tell us a time and place absolutely
no details none so we show up my mom is
in this not in the same attire but she's
definitely not part of theme the amount
of times she went up to every single
person working there waiter going is
this a black T it is this a black T it
she's losing it s are laughing with my
girlfriend but we knew we had to get out
we had to leave Scarlett facetimes us
cuz she ditched the party she knew knew
what was cool her usual and she
facetimes us and she looks like she's at
the most epic nightclub ever so I said
we're leaving we make it there right
before midnight it was probably 5
minutes before midnight I don't know how
we did that let me tell you I danced my
little piglets right off we
went I will say I will say no plan was
better than having a plan because this
ended up being such a fun night oh yeah
like Scarlet was the MVP of the night
this
girl
was you know I I would say she took
advantage of the free
alcohol and she did it well she did do
it well sopia you get runner up because
of two reasons why one you got a kiss at
New Year no I didn't I didn't I saw you
with my eyes I didn't I swear I didn't I
saw 30 minutes after you still kiss
someone also I didn't expect it to
happen I was kind of I don't know if you
watched me by the way it literally I'm
not not exaggerating it looked like you
were like a linebacker and he was the
football that's how like fast and
forceful you just went into his face I
he went into mine right a 100% by the
way on waxers no I would admit if I was
the one making the first move cuz I
would own that [__] he was the one that
make the first move and I was actually
super caught off guard because I to be
honest I wasn't expecting anything I I
honestly I went into this night going
new year new me no boys no problems
let's go and then of course she meets
someone do the opposite going into that
was one reason you were running up that
night the second reason was when we got
home and we were stumbling in it's about
3:00 in the morning and we're all in
Scarlet's room and we're taking off our
dresses we're getting ready for bed and
sopia when she takes off her strapless
dress she's got a sticky bra on girls
you know the chicken cutlet kind yeah
okay attached to her entire chest all
the way down her stomach is probably 50
pieces of conf confetti I had confetti
all over it looked like it looked like a
shirt like he could have been like a it
could have been like a New Year's outfit
like me that could have PE myself a
little bit I was so I just unet my dress
took off cis's cackling I'm so confused
I have my glasses on I have my sleep
shorts
confetti all over my sticky body The
Hangover was horrendous but I think that
was the first fun New Year I've had in a
long time and it kind of made me
optimistic about entering the new year
really I don't know I say this every
single year about a new year I said this
is going to be my year I'm going to make
change I'm going to do this I'm going to
feel this way it always happens to be
worse than the year before yeah I agree
but so far the Vibes are up for me yeah
The Vibes are good The Vibes were good I
will agree with that I think that this
is a good start I mean sans's MRI brain
appointment everything else was good and
I'm I'm excited because we have a lot of
good things coming up this year you know
what we should talk about because in
terms of going into this new year with
high Vibes good energy there's a trend
that I'm So Into I know people have been
making fun of it but I think it's such a
good way to remind yourself it's the ins
and Outlet it's what your ins are for
this year what you're leaving behind
outs let yeah do you want me to go first
you want to go first you go first okay
are we doing ins or outs let's do outs
first okay overc committing like saying
yes to things I don't see yes to
hangovers I'm not doing that I'm
preparing for not a hangover next time
Instagram stalking oh my God I literally
okay go on Taylor
Swift I was going to write that but then
I didn't want you hating on me I I'm not
going to lie look I I respect her I love
her music but I got a little bit too out
of myself with the whole like Obsession
Taylor I think she casted a spell on me
or something dwell on past relationships
yes moving forward bad sleep clutter
fast fashion procrastinating
internalizing bad behavior um tequila
shots I'm done with tequila shots I
can't do that anymore mindless snacking
mindless mindless snacking you want to
hang out with s i at at 3:00 3 p.m. let
me tell you something about 300 p.m.
when 300 p.m. hits in our
apartment no more snacks left in the
pantry all consumed
every day PopCorners gone gluten-free
pretzels gone what else do we have it's
like Sal crackers Sal crackers gone
that's that's exclusively for suine I
have like the weird chips that are Right
Mindless snacking yeah mindless snacking
just like not having to just doing do it
over I'm almost done overthinking
situations acne scars you're cut off you
can't just say no they're on your
face they're they're here they're going
to go away um stressing about future
nightclubs High screen time big friend
group hold on sopie you're going so fast
okay stressing about future okay
nightclubs I'm over at nightclubs I
don't well I don't love it any well
you're 25 I'm just more I'm more in the
bar chill scene now I'm feeling that I
don't really like
the hence other than the fact that I
just did that a couple days ago that was
out um High screen time like I don't
need to see six hours on my phone and
shock myself um big friend group making
a little smaller that's out yeah I don't
I like having friend groups but I feel
like I I say yes to a lot hence overc
committing and I kind of want to you
know tight in my you only need two good
friends you really don't need that many
friends you need it's perfect you need
like three loyal if you have good um
mascara I'm I'm just not into mascara
you're wearing mascara right now yeah so
you're already every day I'm talking
about mascara every day like I'm
currently on a podcast here's the thing
I put on my list reducing the amount of
eye makeup
for my outs right yeah and then I
thought realistically that's never going
to happen with me that's you I don't
really wear that much I just love it I
have two more hit workouts like super
high intensity I my body is already on
like a very high Coral level like I just
have a very I get very stressed you do
hit I've never seen you do a hit workout
in your life hit workouts are even just
including like like running or doing
anything like super heavyweight training
it's just kind of going to Pilates long
walks like more Leisure yeah and I mean
I did not me I'm like Barry's boot camp
every day I'm good and then dating just
because dating just because I'm not
going to lie all of your outs are kind
of my ins okay what's your outs
okay some are repeating so I'm not
surprised that like that but I'm leaving
in 2023
fomo that's a good one I prefer my couch
anyway I don't need to be out yeah tummy
AES every day they're out I'm canc it's
a lie I think it's a lie hot girls have
tummy aches hot girls have IBS and hot
girls have migrain mytic acne yes um I'm
leaving this in 2023 for sure recycling
men for example old dates wait actually
I should add that to my list that's good
one that's a good one if an ex or an old
date comes up and you stop seeing them
for a
reason why are you letting them back
into your circle why I agree I agree
only but you let him back in if he's
like the one but he he would have been
the one weeks ago when you had someone
from my past was like the one no well
specifically mine they're not the ones
impostor
syndrome ah yes because this year I'm so
so so excited about my passion projects
and I want to pursue them and I don't
want to feel one like I'm not capable or
two that it's embarrassing that I want
to pursue these things it's almost the
weirdest part about it is saying it and
speaking into exist to other people is
more embarrassing to me than actually
doing it and failing at it like why
that's your dream that like go for it oh
I talk way more than I should I think
you should go for it yeah imposter
syndrome having the ick I'm so done with
people saying oh he's got this ick I
don't want to see him is annoying that
means you're just judging people too
harshly I don't like that fair hangovers
yeah there you go I'm leaving rip long
acrylic Nails you're taking those off
taking them off hold on let's not get
what let's not get twisted I'm having
short acrylic nails I'm not you're going
to this side now sopia I'm still wearing
acrylic nails just not Catwoman length
they're really long thank you okay this
one I'm definitely leaving out fake
grabbing your wallet on the first date
I'm done with it by the way it's no but
do you know what I mean every first date
you're like reach into your purse and
you're like oh don't worry I got the
bill really when I didn't even bring my
wallet anyway why do we do that if they
asked you out they should they should
just pay yeah it's so awkward for me
okay I like that um and my out was also
stalking people on Instagram I kind of
wrote that one for you CU I don't really
do that I I stock for you so how how
you're out is not having Sophia stock
people for you I don't even ask you to
you just do it for that's true I just do
it for her cuz it's so fun okay me go in
my ins I like these outs these outs are
good okay so ins ready I feel like we're
on very similar ins home cooking yeah
right Sophia you're the worst chef ever
I'm going to learn you almost set the
tin foil on fire the other day that was
the oil on the tin foil I'm going to do
it but that's what I'm bringing it in
girls nights in like hosting a little
bit more having girls over whatever
history
podcasts instead of listening to so much
music learning something learning about
the Roman Empire educating yourself Mar
and twet something um volunteering on
weekends I want to start finding a place
that I can always go to and you know do
my part on a Sunday yes and that means
getting rid The Hangover so I can
actually attend PM journaling like
journaling at night I love journaling I
know she always gives me [__] about
journaling but I love it I've been doing
it for years and it's just such a good
is so boring to me stop I'm not done
okay yeah well mine's more Wellness
stuff so some of the girl Wellness
girlies are going to like this stuff
okay um prioritizing my hormon in gutal
because things L have been imbalanced as
we can see next one's clear skin we're
bringing her back um dating for marriage
like not that's so loaded that's so
loaded I don't think that loaded I do
because I think if you're putting it out
there that you're only dating for
marriage no that's not my point to this
because it does okay look it sounds
loaded but my intention isn't loaded my
intention is I'm only going to say yes
to people that I actually feel like I
have a good connection with that I'm not
dating just because I'm dating because I
see something that could progress into
something because I'm I would rather
honestly go on no dates this year and
then go on a 100 dates with people that
were half-assing it the whole time
that's how I feel okay um ski weekends
ski weekends yes I I love skiing now I
want to do cabin trips I want to do that
with friends so that's one of them it's
almost done sober nights
out I like going out sober I like hate I
love it now it feels so good I love it I
love it it's so good also we're doing
sober January right now so so far so
good for both of us except hold on we
said we're doing sober January ex with
the exceptions of dates and if you had a
really bad day exactly and neither one
of those things are happening for me
those happening for you very soon the
dates not the bad days oh thank you
clarifying okay I'll go pass tall
candles Opera tall candles yes I want to
have like more tall candles
literally goes gut health skin clearing
tall candles tall I think they're such a
Vibe I think they're so cool yeah okay
Opera I love Opera I want to go to more
Opera stuff bare Nails keeping it like
this low impact workouts girl boss
mentality kind of going off of what you
were saying about you know not feeling
bad about it just going for it Classic
Movies Books and Music getting back into
that cuz I did that in like 2020 thinner
eyebrows thinner eyebrows I like my
eyebrows a little bit more shaped not so
bushy okay um okay I'm almost done
natural hair okay guess what probably on
this next episode I'll be having a
brunette moment s has now converted and
understood why I need to cuz she felt my
hair and it is um thinner than normal
not happy about it um okay sunrise and
sunset walks like taking my like waking
up early you're going to get up at 5
a.m. you if you had said that I would
ask you that question are you going to
get up at 5:00 a.m. the sun doesn't rise
at 5 I can 57 6 o' I can get up and
still make the sunrise okay yes and it's
relaxing it's good to get your vitamin D
and then almost done um sophisticated
outfits calling friends weekly singing I
want to get back into singing okay um
wearing glasses over contacts like kind
of embracing that I am nearsighted okay
and learning new talent and writing
every day okay thank you this is a very
Wellness self-help list my whole 2024
goal just overall before s starts is
just more aligning myself and figuring
out exactly who I am what I want I'm so
over I think the last year has been very
much like even for her too we've been
going going going kind of clouded
everything that we are at a core I feel
like I just I think I kind of let who I
am versus what I was doing go if that
makes sense and so I just want to get
back to Bas level Sophia natural hair
natural nails yes calm not drinking as
much much
yeah podcast that are history I'm a
little uh hesitant to share my list why
cuz yours was so well thought out yeah
cuz I really am caring about this stuff
right now I've got like seven okay in
saying no yes you need that number two
hard balling so when on dates with men
I'll straight up just
say what do you want a relationship a
girlfriend a one night fun just ask fun
then you get your answer and you don't
have to waste time I agree with that I
feel like more people need to do that
hard balling
okay complimenting strangers I wrote
that one down and I delet I do this
actually a lot that's what I was going
to say I deleted it because you do that
a lot I do that a lot and I love it and
I don't know why more people don't just
makes their day think about the times
that you've been complimented on and
that holds with you forever if someone
said I was great and blue I'd wear it
forever yeah um boxers as short
what there's a new uh style there's a
new style Trend I think it's called The
Eclectic grandpa style I saw it on
Pinterest and it's basically like boxers
with ankle socks and like oversiz kind
of sheer sunglasses and then a hat and
maybe like a big bomber Jack you be a
dude complimenting girls wearing boxer
shorts hard
balling whatever um what are you doing I
also put hes SL volunteering so that was
funny okay cute overdressing I'm So Into
overdressing I love it hence our outfits
right
now you try to [__] on me for not
overdressing yes I want to write that
one down too cuz I like this I think
that more people need to go out and
don't be embarrassed to oh you know what
you know what it is don't look at a
piece of clothing that you love and say
oh I'll see it for next time what next
time I mean you see me when I go out I
always have the ridiculous FR jackets on
no you look good and people well it's
fun fashion is fun and I think you're
taking a risk is exciting I think it's
also okay to once in a while like I do
this sometimes go out you think it's a
good outfit and maybe it's not a good
outfit it's fine no one remembers your
outfit in the first place but it's good
to start doing it to get comfortable
with it yes um and my last one is world
domination what are you Plankton like
what are you saying world domination I
just want to dominate dominate the world
yeah all right or at least New York like
Manhattan
nice yeah okay cool cool yeah that's
like that's actually kind of like a
that's kind of a cool ending world
domination world domination why wouldn't
I want that for 2024 what do you mean
who doesn't want to dominate the world
first law of order first order bring
back the Hunger Games law of order bring
back the Hunger Games bring back The
Purge Su so kill people just the X's
kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm
kidding worst ever kidding kidding
kidding okay so I think everyone should
make an inal list because every time I
think about this upcoming year I revert
to that list a lot and will I say that
I've right now in the last couple days
completely hit it no but I think once we
go back to New York will be a lot easier
which Speaking of we have big updates
about New York big updates and when I
say big updates it is something that
Sistine and I are currently in the
middle of dealing with and that is we're
officially moving out again again yes
you've heard that right third time
moving out fourth fourth time and
there's a special Twist on it we are not
living with each
other whose idea do you think this
was sopia thinks because she's
27 that living with her sister is just
too it's she's too old for that
literally I have never said that yes you
did you're like I think at my age I need
to be living alone no no yes I need well
that's true I did say I need to live
alone at this point but it's not like
that and I can explain why unless you
want to explain your reasoning I don't
have a reasoning you're leaving me okay
I want to be together I love you but I
I'm
lonely I'm a lonely person I am a I'm
going to make myself Lonely by living
alone but we look I just think this the
reason why I want to move out and this
is nothing to do with cinee at all it's
not because I don't want to live with
her it's because the area that we live
in I don't love anymore and it's just
not serving me and I hate that I just
said not serving me it sounds so stupid
but it's just a crazy environment and I
can feel myself needing a bit more quiet
of an area and some space so when I say
cine is going to pretty much stay in the
general area that we've been living and
I am going like exponentially yeah you
guys it's not like she's
moving 15 blocks away from me I can deal
with that she's literally going to the
opposite end of Manhattan and I'm going
to the other end of Manhattan so it'll
probably take an hour by car just to
reach each other yeah so will I see her
probably not she's choosing the whole
wholesome life dog in the stroller all
these little bab what are you looking
for for your place cuz you that's the
thing she's saying I want the more quiet
life slower what do you because you want
more energy you want more yeah well the
thing is I'm GNA need to not rely on you
for company anymore so I have to be
around like my friends people my age
more of the loud Lively energy part of
New York and that's fine I'm just sad
how do you feel sad I mean elaborate
that I'm not happy I I don't know I
think you know what's funny admitting
that you're a lonely person and you like
living with people is something that is
shamed and frowned upon and I don't
understand why because everyone says oh
you have to live on your own it helps
you grow up and learn who you are and
blah blah blah that's not me I'm I need
someone to talk to who are we going to
watch reality TV with no it's true I I
will say I will say that I have been
thinking lately going okay like you know
who am I going to cook dinner with who
am I going to watch these shows with who
am I going to hang out with when I wake
up in the morning who's going to buy the
groceries cuz yours you don't I do I do
it every time I have just she like I
have a couple times I have gone to the I
have to eat got to not going to sit
there the whole time no it's going to be
a very very weird transition but I do
think that you know at least we do a lot
of our stuff together workwise and I
think it's going to be kind of fun like
going to each other's Apartments every
couple times a week we have sleepovers
yeah we're going to try I'm going to try
to get one of those beds that I or like
couch beds I can like full bring in you
know yes that's what I'm doing freaking
out cuz that move is going to happen
about
so soon 45 days so 45 days it's so soon
and at the same time we're moving out is
the same time season two of the reality
show comes out is the same week that
we're doing press for the show is the
same time I'm
gonna um have a panic attack yeah no
same time to seen scch have a panic
attack yeah that week no it's a lot this
up I would say like I was hoping to go
into 2024 with a little bit of a calming
start but it's really going off heavy
handed and it's taking it I'm taking it
in the jaw so it's a lot to much but I
get it you want the wholesome route you
want to eat gluten free [__] and okay
have fun taking shots and I will [__]
you know I will by the way this podcast
is going to be on my back I'm going to
have the stories from every weekend I
have some stories of what doing a puzzle
helping an older lady AC cross the
street there we go I maybe well I want
to start fostering dogs I could tell you
about my dog stories yeah right yeah
right you're not fostering dogs I am
Foster dog dog sopia you already pee
enough on the carpet you cannot have a
dog I wish I could think of a good
comeback but I can't I'm bad at this
it's okay um actually so we're going
back to LA yeah wow in what two days two
days Sophia was very impressed with me
actually on the way to shoot this
podcast because a new thing I want to do
this year is to not care so much and if
I want something go after it shamelessly
and if it works out amazing if it
doesn't who cares like I want to stop
feeling embarrassment let me preface
this really quick that just to give you
a context of why I'm very impressed with
sine is because I was headed to La for a
work meeting and I was like oh I'm just
going to make a trip out of it by going
for this sounds bad no it's not doesn't
sound bad it's a work I was like okay I
need to only be there for like two days
top so why don't I just extend my trip
and see all my friends and so I told to
Sten scarlet and last minute they booked
their flight they booked a hotel and
they're they're joining me so so Scarlet
has friends that she's seeing in La yeah
Sophia has meetings and friends that
she's seeing in
La I have no one
so every single night they have dinner
plans and lunch plans so what did I do I
made my own plans I have a date every
single night that I'm there she I I
actually I will and I'll say this on the
way here she planned one yeah and by the
way I was the middleman yeah I said
Sophia ask him the mutual friend right
now do it what happened it worked out I
asked the friend I said I'm asking for a
friend is your friend single and he said
yes and I said this friend of mine is my
sister actually not for me but how
exciting though and they're all great
options actually I'm going to plan some
meetings with them there I got to be
productive I can't just go on dates
every night I mean I'll do something
good I think it could be kind of fun
just to go on dates just to fly out to
I'm literally flying there just to talk
to
it's going to be so good so much content
for next week yeah it's going to be
awesome but I'm impressed I was say to
16 I go I can't think of one person I
want to go on a date with if I was if I
had if you had me at gunpoint right now
I could not conjure up three dayses at
all at all and you're like Sophia yes
you can you it's you are impressive
you're a special breed I don't know how
you do it I'm a mix you know I'm a mut
I'm a mut it's difficult because the way
we're meeting people now is through soci
social media like say if you're like oh
set me up with so and so you send her
their
Instagram then I was thinking about it
the other day right because how do you
I'll ask you this question how do you
think people perceive you based off of
your
Instagram I think they think
I'm people have said I look nice on
Instagram I look more conservative just
because yeah I'm just more like nerdy is
but pretty like nerdy pretty I don't
know when I I don't see nerdy at all
really I just see hot blonde so I was
looking at mine and I watched this um
Alex Earl posted this Tik Tok the other
day and she was saying am I annoying
she's like I just posted this video and
I think I'm annoying I was looking at my
page and I
said am I a [__] cuz what I'm posting I
look super [__] I look like I have no
character no personality like I don't
show any of my interests I just take
photos on my Instagram I don't even
smile in my photos I just take artsy
Pinterest looking well your angle no but
I don't like well if you look at the
difference between ours you are trying
to portray style fashion but that's the
issue this is where I'm getting at
what to the naked eye it's just oh a
girl that does this yeah you can't tell
that I'm somewhat intelligent or fun or
or has a hobby or is even happy cuz I
just look sad in all my photos like so
I'm thinking I'm like
maybe I'm just intimidating and maybe
that's why we're still single don't put
me into this you why I I've I've made my
singleness a
decision yeah right Sophia shut up I
have you you are intimidating how does
it feel that you're bridesma again can
you stop every episode bringing up the
fact I'm a bridesmaid I'll stop when the
invitation stop
I love it it's fun I'm excited okay well
to wrap it all up I think everyone
should go into this year with an instant
out list I think that it is a really
funny conversation also to talk about
with your friends because honestly
there's things I learned about cinee
that she's expecting to go into this
year leaving and bringing that I didn't
know about yeah and I hope some of you
actually did do the um eating grapes
under a table because that I wonder if
it will work we missed you guys last
week we love you guys Happy New Year we
will see you next Tuesday bye bye